this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman every week
we also like to take a look at movies
and TV shows that hundreds of pairs of
eyes have seen before they reach the
audience and yet invariably
mistakes and bloopers reach you the
audience it's called [ __ ] that should
not be this we [ __ ] that should not be
is from The Wizard of Oz the Wizard of
Oz 1939 75 I get tired of talking about
this movie ken can't we [ __ ] retire
it like a jersey everyone's always like
all this the [ __ ] 74th anniversary of
The Wizard of Oz is 75th anniversary
know what's better movie than this
Ironman there I [ __ ] said it Wow what
did they steal from your trunk when you
went to see Wizard of Oz you got a
hard-on for this movie I hate The Wizard
of Oz I don't hate it but I'm [ __ ] 43
they've been talking about this movie
since I was a baby man they would force
me to watch it every year on TV I was
imaginative and [ __ ] 43 years later I'm
[ __ ] done stop talking about this
movie it was honored at the Oscars this
year no and I couldn't believe it I was
like we're still [ __ ] this
I could wile away the hours yeah yeah
person with the flowers can sultan with
the rain you can't melt my heart with
the thoughts I'd be thinkin I'd be smart
as mr. Lincoln if I only had a brain
come on it's fine dude it's fine but I
tried forcing I would not be just my
head offal its stuffing I chew my heart
off full of pain oh my god now you're
making me hate it again
I tried forcing this [ __ ] on my kid man
when she was little all the way from
when she was a child up to she's 14 man
every year she's like I ain't having
this
and I'm like right are you all like
right she's all like and you're like
totally yeah and we Instagram dude's are
those selfies yeah why what are we
talking about it now for its got [ __ ]
that should not be in it all right
though not I'm all for if you say it's
like mistake grid and I'm all for that
Thanks there's one glaring one that I
never noticed before and I've seen it
each year because I love this film he
really yeah they're going through the
haunted forest as they're want to do in
this film and they got scary trees and
[ __ ] and they're going through the
forest and something happens with the
Scarecrow that I never noticed before
I'm gonna roll the scene see if you can
catch it if not we got a still store of
what happens in there but it's it's
inexplicable how this happens go ahead
[Music]
that's ridiculous sports that's silly
don't you believe in spooks no why don't
you see what I was talking about let's
throw the picture up all of a sudden the
middle of the film for no goddamn good
reason the Scarecrow's back in heat it's
never seen before and never after this
scene but somehow out of his pants
scarecrow becomes dirty [ __ ] hairy
when you played the clip I was looking
at a gun I don't remember their gun but
remembers that we've all watched this
film and no notice the giant [ __ ]
piece he's caring he's about to pop a
cap in the wicked witch's ass if he's
got that [ __ ] gun why's he pulled out
like an hour earlier in the film it
would've been so useful
hey scarecrow remember when the Wicked
Witch showed up tried to kill us all you
[ __ ] shoot her you had a gun credits
it's a short little film I never saw
that's [ __ ] this guy's sent me this
clip Jeremy Conrad he is his name he
said you ever notice his scarecrows
packing heat then with the farce is it
no did you cross-reference it or is it
just the clip he sent you no I looked at
the movie I pulled that from the vets
from there yeah I thought maybe somebody
who stood on your something like that
and but that's for real yeah if you go
look at my copy which I swore I'd never
[ __ ] do ever again like you have one
but if I pull it out I'm gonna see that
gun in my version if you watch The
Wizard of Oz every version of The Wizard
of Oz in that scene in the heart of
haunted forest he's doing this he's
Barney Fife and all over the place
[Music]
you